el infierno puede estar a 200 km de este
aserradero tiene forma de triángulo
dorado queda entre los estados mexicanos
de sinaloa chihuahua y durango y allí
sigifredo fue vasallo de los grandes
narcotraficantes
me agarró la estatal judicial y
meta con el pincho bote mate cabrones a
lo y así me vi a refugiar y así
estoy a gusto
sigifredo pagó 15 años de cárcel por
haber matado a 12 personas entre primos
y hermanos cuando los cultivos distintos
a la coca eran rentables para los narcos
en la década del 90
yo sembraba ante amapola y marihuana y
nunca me salió nada completo no viene a
trabajar aquí y aquí está el nivel de
busto sí porque hay aquí estoy comiendo
bien tranquilamente y con mi familia
como sigifredo miles de agricultores
migraron hacia la silvicultura una
industria maderera de más de 1000
millones de dólares
pero qué tan equitativo es este negocio
para los mexicanos la respuesta es poco'
méxico importa el 67 por ciento de la
madera que consume y solo estados como
durango se destacan en una industria que
a menudo viola la ley forestal como
explica el gerente del aserradero salto
de camellones de la samba
echándole ganas a hacer las cosas mal
sería como extraer más volumen del que
nos autorizan sería como que nos valga
un tumbar árboles
y no tener a los trabajadores en las
condiciones en que se encuentran
cerca del aserradero el gerente y un
líder de la comunidad vigila en el
territorio de donde proviene la madera y
que heredaron de la ley agraria de la
revolución mexicana a estas comunidades
en méxico se les llama ejidos y con el
gobierno de andrés manuel lópez obrador
les fue recortado el 70% del presupuesto
con que contaban en años anteriores
así que le planteamos este
pese al abandono del estado los tejidos
de durango son los reyes de la madera
mexicana con el 28 por ciento de la
producción nacional
vamos a marcar aquel árbol el que estaba
inclinado
me pasas el diámetro por favor me lo
dices fuerte
39 ok
en altura 25 el ingeniero forestal
carlos zapata trabaja como asesor de los
ejidos de durango les enseña cómo talar
un bosque de pinos para que sea un
ecosistema sostenible
para seleccionar los árboles tenemos que
ver primeramente en darles una vista
total al árbol si tiene algún defecto
como puede ser este un daño puede un
rayo que esté enfermo que esté plagado
este este árbol o vamos a marcar
para infortunio de las comunidades
forestales la tala ilegal acecha a sus
bosques según la comisión nacional
forestal se trata de un delito que
genera un lucro de más de 350 millones
de dólares anuales y que lidera el
crimen organizado
[Aplausos]
la solución podría estar en volver a
méxico más competitivo en la materia
pero mientras su superficie forestal
triplica la de finlandia su producción
de madera es diez veces menor
esta parte de aquí este cambio no acaba
de llegar lo están descargando en este
punto porque es material certificado en
materia prima certificada
joel mesa coordinadora ambiental de una
empresa social y rural en santiago d
papasquiaro marca los pinos que le han
comprado a varios ejidos de durango son
árboles de bosques certificados por el
fsc el forest stewardship council un
sello de calidad que permite a esta
empresa comunitaria competir en mercados
ecológicos verdes
la importancia de este material
certificado es que viene de bosques bien
manejados nos aseguramos de que esos
bosques nos vayan a durar muchos años
más
del 100% de los troncos que llegan a
esta empresa sólo el 45 por ciento se
aprovecha para la demanda del sector de
la construcción y la carpintería el
restante 55% se desechaba por falta de
conocimiento pero ahora se recicla bajo
el liderazgo del ingeniero raymundo
valdivia gerente de producción nosotros
tenemos la encomienda la consigna de no
desperdiciar absolutamente nada de lo
que nos llega de madera de crucería
un ejemplo es esta caldera gigante el
operario empuja la serrín para quemarlo
a 180 grados celsius y generar la
energía con que se alimenta toda la
planta de producción
qué tanta electricidad produce
por turno de ocho horas estamos
produciendo en promedio
66 mil kilowatt hora
en otras palabras esta empresa que
normalmente pagaría una factura mensual
de energía de aproximadamente
75 mil dólares mensuales tan sólo paga
30 dólares no estamos parejas
una eficiencia energética que surge de
la urgencia de competitividad de durango
sobre todo en un país como méxico que
pudiendo ser autosuficiente en la
producción de madera se beneficia el
tratado de libre comercio con sus
vecinos del norte y le compra la mayoría
a su principal socio eeuu